[Music]
go
all right our own cooking confidence
coach Nanny Bobby is in studio again and
this time
udom Hamrick the president of Nevada
operations at Chapman Automotive the
sponsors of this segment and today this
smells delicious we are making Taco Mac
and Cheese how fun does that sound it
sounds and looks fun and smells
delicious okay so we are hello hey there
welcome it's good to be here I'm always
so happy to have everything branded in
the Chapman logo here
and your new store is where it's uh
right there on Boulder Highway 3470 and
looking phenomenal and doing well doing
well and your customers are happy as
always all right I love that there you
go and they're gonna love Taco Mac and
Cheese we're going to feed them
something so please serve this with him
but they buy a new car yeah
you get a recipe okay so we're gonna
start this out with onions and we're
gonna sweat the onions as I've done
already and what we're going to add is
what we already did add is this tomato
paste so notice that this tomato paste
is very very red and what we do in this
pot here is we caramelize it with the
onions and when you say sweat the onions
I know you've explained this before but
in case someone didn't catch it yeah my
favorite thing to say
some transparent and gets rid of all
their s what have you do you do sweat
the English salt and heat okay okay good
question
translucent onions are a good thing yes
they are so what we have in this now is
we have caramelized in a lot of brown
bits and we're going to add the garlic
yes the thing about garlic is that you
don't want to cook up more than 30
seconds because it'll start to burn it
keeps away better 30 sec
and if it starts to burn the first thing
that you're going to do is you're just
going to add this goes into the recipe
anyway just a little bit of beef stock
and that will help it bring down the
heat it'll stop it from cooking so your
garlic won't burn and then it also
deglazes the plant and that's what I was
noticing right now look at that it
brings out all the brown bits the brown
bucket was burnt but it's not do you
have a particular Beanstalk you like
beef stock beef beef stock that would I
say I thought it's a bean
if I did I meant beef
organic anything organic okay okay so
we're going to move from here and take
you to the next stage I'll just turn
that down okay so this is now ground
beef already added to this okay okay and
then what we are going to do is we are
going to add the taco seasoning which I
made with Rocky in January when we did
the um Whole30 recipe right we made this
taco seasoning which has can you read
that
chili powder kosher salt
smoked paprika cumin onion powder garlic
powder oregano and black pepper this is
not the same step she made in January
though this is fresh for this recipe it
would last that long yeah I would assume
I'm amazing two to three tablespoons
just sprinkle it in there if you want to
mix that that would be great it really
does it smells fantastic I'll do it okay
and we also added one and a half cups of
beef stock into this and we let it
simmer and reduce something yes look at
this came a little bit thicker and now
it's ready and what we are going to do
is add the macaroni great we got about a
minute left here okay add the macaroni
here we go you pick up the pot I'll put
it in that makes a deal okay let's do it
there you go look at this how about that
maybe that's enough huh that's a good
start yeah okay and I'm gonna let you
add the cheddar cheese all of this in
there yep
okay I'm a big cheese guy so you are I
love cheese of course it's meant to be a
one-pot dinner right one pot Skillet so
I made it in two different pots but you
would make it all in one I just did that
to show the different stages okay all
the cheese and you would garnish in this
one pot if you like with the sour cream
right the avocado the green and also if
you want to put in your taco shell it
would be ikama taco shells regular flour
taco shells or pita bread pita bread and
that's it how do you like that that is
wonderful
and you can find this recipe on
nannybubby.com or on my Instagram page
as always there you go delicious thank
you guys so much I'll leave you there
all right check out Nanny Bubby's
kitchen and Garden on social media and
online at manibubby.com get onions too I
also want to thank Chapman Automotive
for sponsoring this event all right Don
take a bite and tell us how cool I am
going